if you draw lines in the sand the ocean
is going to wipe you the [ __ ] out so the
art of the pivot the art of the loss the
art of reading the market it's all
predicating the same [ __ ] which is check
your [ __ ] Google at the door no the
markets bigger than you and [ __ ]
react to it or even a [ __ ] booth you
ain't gotta be up in the hall
whoever will be to corporate talks about
ownership and leverage 1800 Texas
outdoors every should not only be
closing the gap on the long-form
creative videos better exchanger visits
it's also the contact and electric skill
and other strategies that you add on and
[ __ ] do exactly what you guys figured
out the first time and close the gap of
what you guys missed the second time and
make sure that you crush the third time
thank you
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
cause water questions destino for me was
right
how am I to placate them in she started
to freak out just a little bit more yeah
I think I get that I'm gonna be a real
good piece of advice maybe the best
piece of ice I'm excited is the big one
cuz you have no choice if you want to
win big yeah how long
well then since then you really have to
realize that you have to go the other
way I didn't want to do it either
yeah it's you know you know like it when
it comes to quick spin it's easy to
pretend it's easy it's easy to get away
with when you have that charisma
manipulation listen man don't do as I
say do as I do I [ __ ] shut my mouth
and [ __ ] built a big company yeah you
know I was quiet
I was micro confident loud in a liquor
meeting and you know but not I didn't
say like as you know yeah I just did
listen you can say anything if you're
doing yeah Muhammad Ali was saying I'm
the greatest but was winning fight yeah
if you're going to start a little media
presence but I already have a little
immediate Britain's booked to spot like
walking or something like that what if I
come by laughing yeah cuz I'm just
tweeting it because it just makes me
think that way so much Gary come on man
okay well cause it thank you going to
film on my phone on your phone I'm in
with that into their mad ah like we [ __ ]
it up yeah hey guys I'm snapchat listen
first of all hacking the ad product tips
number one it's under price you should
be doing this real quick tip for the
snapchat community we are living through
the greatest era ever and so many of you
are going to get a job or do the normal
thing you need to explore in your late
teens and early 20s slide [ __ ] go to
places this is the time to be risky not
the time to be super conservative
because [ __ ] mom and dad said
so so promised me right here on snapchat
now you're going to go and do random
interesting wild [ __ ] try new businesses
meet new friends try different talents
become that maker you always wanted
shoot for the goddamn stars now because
it gets a lot harder when you're 13 14
stop [ __ ] up and go do [ __ ] you think
I do this hot hot in limit Edition Moosa
when he was at Nike game to me which so
I've seen reloaded
what are you a nerd horse clowns doing
you're struggling I need to bring in the
puzzle you need to bring in the big dog
way to drive in this truck you guys do
two adjectives like crushing and
grinding and then all of a sudden bring
it all I ended with was struggling
what's up guys
super comp swipe up right now looking
for people responsible action Miller's
football camp get the details on his
post they're looking for food brands
looking for some other brand if you're
interested let me know Gary at
vaynermedia calm
that's why pop booty humor me it's that
complimentary transfer stuff yes yep
have a question so I always rather talk
to you than I've been doing okay right
now let's go grab the first episode of
that had to go through uh so I haven't
historically had are you recording good
I haven't historically had a pivot but I
Mike I haven't had the macro pivot often
but I'd micro pivoted my whole career I
think pivoting is looked upon sometimes
as a fake positive or a negative
I think of pivoting as an offense so
unlike my friends a companion where
we're actually actually would say
companion been in pivot we we pivoted as
an offense we had to react to something
and we added features I've changed my
product offering at vaynermedia every
day like one day we won't sell anything
that asked you to do with Facebook
snapchat Instagram did I pivot no I
[ __ ] went to the market
their time you can think over just a
little bit more context on deploying
energy time money into something it
didn't work
oh I sign I mean I mean there's some
times where things have gone out of
business site I had cork music CEO
Arkady a wine social network didn't
succeed
I had forests forr
St a community for designer developers
didn't work now those were places where
I was co-founder where I wasn't the real
operator so I'm not going to take those
losses on my on my resume though I was
part of the team that co-founded it I
funded it personally so you know I don't
have all successes I just don't respect
my losses
like yours are quite familiar I don't
give a [ __ ] and think what you think or
what anybody thinks it's a loss if
you're an entrepreneur you use it's like
being a UFC fighter like everybody has
an hour like having losses
I moved on with [ __ ] Jesus because
I'm a [ __ ] winner this is in 2009
probably ten eleven yeah yeah and it
down by they are specific about the arms
the ability to you know the act not
being romantic is everything like if you
draw lines in the sand the ocean is
going to wipe you the [ __ ] out so the
art of the pivot the art of the loss the
art of reading the market it's all
predicating the same [ __ ] which is check
your [ __ ] Google at the door no the
markets bigger than you and [ __ ]
react to it or you're going to [ __ ]
booth everybody's mad about the center
fishing gang and you say in one party
perspective
[Music]
this perspective man it's just
perspective just game-changer where I
would be what by this incredible but I
have great perspective
III I do I just I it was more fun
watching them change their perspective
my crew than me cuz I'm like I'm in that
mindset I'm in the [ __ ] feet in the
dirt [ __ ] [ __ ] outside like I'm
ghetto I'm much more ghetto than they
think I'm [ __ ] much more ghetto than
they think like it I just mmm and
ghettos the wrong world I'm just more
comp I just more humble like I know what
it tastes like
you can't [ __ ] fabricate that taste
in your mouth when you got [ __ ] two
things one is right now Young Jeezy yes
you're not able to have full paper
that's spending account for you let me
get down on that like because this disc
little house I know works like you have
to have a presence there like so
everyone's been there so like even a
stab when your passport whatever you do
not they just so how do we hack it do I
have to go to China on this trip
there's it's Hong Kong Kong's now China
so jump should I go to China first five
minutes but yes okay so still we need up
with a sumac yeah so let's do a meet-up
in let's do a meet-up in Beijing I'll
fly in land do meet up elite that's your
gangster ass content would you do it
this obviously not a Content caching
right now like all this need to be in it
then weren't we went to war in control
of my time I just wanna what is on your
radar wait otherwise nothing's going to
happen though are you going into this
because the other thing is that I need I
need someone it to you we can actually
speak Chinese so that I can learn it oh
you go faster look at Scott because I
need so as I start auditing all the
content that's going on because we're
putting on all right somebody who speaks
Chinese don't want to intern for six
months on our team we're interested
[Music]
very fun business need to stock read I
wanted to talk to you about so many
things but I think I know about should
all the time so I first I wanted to talk
about the template under degree we think
it was great for me to be there I mean I
probably one of the youngest people in
the studio and and I'm really passionate
about what I do and I love sad I mean
that kind of I'm not very stories and
that's what I want and so about me when
it comes to like approaching my work and
really passionate about every project
inadvertently made it the best so I feel
like many degrees it's actually really
are because because that's clearly what
I want to do so yeah I think you work or
of course whatever there's that like
statue vision how do you really like
your fans in terms of life and I was
among your audience by the way it was a
like you're at the time you found I I
just feel live in real life sometimes I
spend too much time working that I fix
it sometimes I'm not spending enough
time working I fix it like I work a lot
but I also have a wife who's
understanding it's kind of what we
agreed to
you know I'm spending more vacation time
the weekends are very focused so just
trying to be better every day I don't I
don't judge myself I called this me
because I just found out this morning
about what happened I mean I know what
happened macro I didn't put two and two
together so I just want to check in on
you the second you like have any insight
to anything or if there's anything you
need me to do for you usually and that
means meet having me curate a meeting
with every single thing we do here
I'm here for you you know that right
what you really act I just want to make
sure like it's you know like this
engaging the trolling there's things you
can't all right good yeah
please please please use me if I can
help
[Music]
[Music]